[Música]
bienvenidos a cultura de france24 hoy me
disculparán que barra para casa porque
este 2020 las producciones de españa han
arrasado al punto que cada mes surgían
las mejores del año
la candidata al oscar la trinchera
infinita ha sido la mejor película por
la angustia de quienes se ocultaron del
régimen franquista pero el año del
descubrimiento también se ha valorado
filme del año con mar del plata- dándole
el actor mayor
esta es un fresco documental que revela
en la lucha obrera del 92 y como pasado
y futuro se sobreponen a la fecha de
supuesta bonanza en planos contra planos
es la gente la que narran 90 años de
realidad española en un bar y es esa
naturalidad de más del talento y el
idioma así como el soporte y el dinero
del streaming lo que ha consagrado a las
series del país
[Música]
el furor estalló con la casa de papel
pero es fruto de joyas anteriores que
van de los serranos a vis a vis pulseras
rojas o las chicas del cable así se ha
llegado a que el cineasta álex de la
iglesia se une al formato corto con el
thriller satánico costumbrista 30
monedas guau que party antidisturbios y
veneno sean a la vez lo más del 2020 ya
comentamos la primera y estas últimas
son la vida misma la de rodrigo
sorogoyen es el reflejo de un furgón de
antidisturbios que sabe que cae mal pero
se vende necesario pese a ser una bomba
de relojería hasta que un desahucio
evidencia que es el eslabón débil
policial pero más abajo también hay
víctimas
[Música]
mundo hacemos
la bodega
punto
mientras que los javis hacen algo tan
fundamental como dignificar a cristina
ortiz como protagonista una mujer
transexual que fue machacada por la
sociedad que no la dejó ser pero con
tanto poder como para cambiarnos hoy
tú te sentías igual de mujer cuando era
exactamente igual
lo cambió todo ella supo luchar sí pero
no es una mujer peligrosa son mujeres
para las que el mundo peligroso
poder metafórico es lo que tiene la
siguiente cinta land wing de wah ya que
esta noche de reyes no solo es la
representante de costa de marfil ante la
academia de los oscar sino costa de
marfil en sí misma aún cuando la trama
se encierra en la casa de detención y
corrección de abiyán desde allí philip
la coz apela a los jóvenes que son
llamados microbios por atemorizar y
violentar a la población a los
linchamientos colectivos contra ellos ya
la política cuyas elecciones de octubre
dejaron un baño de sangre
la maca de abiyán es la cárcel más
célebre del país pero también el
escenario de esta trama sobre un joven
que se ve envuelto en una lucha entre
prisioneros ansiosos por suceder a su
líder enfermo servil
nuestro como apodado goma este
protagonista debe contener el ambiente
de la prisión narrando una historia que
permita el líder venido a menos
mantenerse un poco más en el poder
si la visión común
así como decide contar la leyenda de
zama un microbio que además es el alias
de los jóvenes delincuentes de costa de
marfil tiene las jons de cómo se para
así poder a amigos
el casting formado en su mayoría por
debutantes ha cambiado la vida al
estudiante bakari koné porque desde su
estreno ha convencido a los marfileños
vamos a motivos y mayores lima y baja de
filipe chino con un kit de killer
passion código y el fenómeno de mejor en
bicicleta realista realista y
comprometido hace eco de las luchas de
poder recientes en el país
no abandonamos el francés y la razón es
que su máximo premio literario goncourt
2020 pasará a la historia bajo el título
la anomalía y el nombre evelio tellier
el autor un liviano presidente del grupo
taller un lipo de aquellos que desde los
70 se ponen una construcción al escribir
y buscan salir airosos de ella cuenta
con 27 libros y en esta novela es además
borgiano metafísico e hiperrealista del
hoy en el año más raro del premio pues
cargado por primera vez desde 1914 lo
tele juega en un 2021 en el que trata
unos personajes que en realidad están
todos en un mismo avión que aterriza dos
veces en una hora
uno nunca espera un premio como el con
cook de hecho uno no escribe para ganar
este certamen y no se puede esperar en
ningún momento que uno lo obtenga por
eso es un premio muy simbólico un premio
único que tiene consecuencias muy
importantes para un autor y
evidentemente el hecho de esperar poder
obtenerlo no estaba para nada en mis
planes
la guinda de esta crónica es el artista
rayón spotify con más de 8.300 millones
de escuchas en un año por supuesto nos
referimos al puertorriqueño band bonich
que este 2020 se ha dirigido gran
romántico del caribe con tres discos
bailables pero despechados y deba ser
dembow pero balada triste robótica en
concreto así es último tour del mundo en
el que benito antonio martínez se corona
prolífico altavoz urbano latino artistas
de constructivo y ser de lo que le da la
gana ojalá nunca por última vez
muchísimas gracias y cuídense
cuando el niño mami más día quizás la
tuya mató tus fantasías si fuera bomba
de policía y le prendiera fuego al que
escribe
y repetir
[Música]